[Música]
[Aplausos]
la industria 4.0 es comunicación todos
los días
utilizamos los celulares todos los días
las empresas se comunican vía internet
nosotros nos comunicamos vía internet
la tecnología ha comenzado a avanzar
desde la primera revolución industrial
cuando comenzamos a ver las máquinas a
vapor segunda revolución industrial
comenzamos a fabricar carros en líneas
tercera revolución industrial comenzamos
a automatizar las empresas computadoras
comienzan a aparecer los robots
comienzan a aparecer el día de hoy
estamos en la cuarta revolución
industrial lo que algunos conocemos como
industria 4.0
que la industria 4.0 que vamos a
comenzar a ver en la industria 4.0 vamos
a tener conceptos como big data internet
de las cosas seguridad nos van a abrumar
con tecnología
el problema es que tenemos que cambiar
paradigmas educativos tenemos que
comenzar a pasar de la teoría a la
práctica estoy convencido que con la
práctica se hace y tenemos mejores
aprendizajes significativos concepto
materias planes de estudio que es vienen
del siglo pasado debemos comenzar a
actualizarlos
los gobiernos las empresas
tienen que comenzar a ver con luces
largas el futuro y comenzar a preparar a
los nuevos profesionales los niños de
hoy en el 2022 o en 2030 ni siquiera
esos puestos o esos trabajos ni siquiera
existen
fíjense árbol el día de hoy vamos a
necesitar personas que sepan de diseño e
impresión tres de las empresas tienen
que comenzar a personalizar sus
productos eso quiere decir que si yo
quiero una camisa de color anaranjado
con botones morados la empresa me la
tiene que dar si quiero un auto que sea
de color fucsia con llantas cuadradas me
lo tiene que vender que no va a
funcionar con llantas cuadradas nos
interesa pero yo lo quiero con llantas
cuadradas
las empresas se van a tener que
automatizar porque quieren ser
eficientes y quieren ser productivas
para eso vamos a necesitar personal que
sepa de robótica mecatrónica
necesitamos vender las empresas tienen
que tener presencia en internet si tiene
presencia en internet necesitan
ciberseguridad hay un estudio del iese
ese al cuadrado que dice que van a
sobrar escucha y bien van a sobrar 1.8
millones de empleos en ciberseguridad
hay un top rank de 100 países panamá
aparece en el ranking número 66 eso
quiere decir que estamos siendo
invadidos por ciberataques
ejemplo de ellos los panamá papers
básicamente un ataque de ciberseguridad
las empresas van a tener equipos esos
equipos tienen sensores los sensores van
a generar millones de datos con los
datos hacemos información y tomamos
decisiones necesitamos gente
especializada en big data para que pueda
procesar esos millones de datos para así
hacer buena información y tomar
decisiones en el futuro el foro
económico mundial hace referencia que
para el año 2022 el 85% de las empresas
va a implementar big data el 75% de las
empresas va a implementar internet de
las cosas
para el año 2022 75 millones de personas
van a perder el empleo por no
actualizarse en la industria 4.0 pero
van a haber 133 millones de nuevos
empleos en la parte de tecnología la
pregunta es quiere ser parte de los 75
millones o quiere ser parte de los 133
millones que tienen empleo no es el
gobierno no son las universidades no son
las escuelas las que te van a preparar
eres tú el que tiene que estar preparado
para la industria 4.0 que ya está aquí
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
no
[Música]